mais on va plus loin avec anne nivat
reporter de guerre indépendante bonjour
anne bonjour vous revenez d'ukraine à le
récit des 34 jours que vous avez passé
là bas est à lire dans le magazine le
point du 25 avril et du 5 mai merci
d'être avec nous face à vous je lui
donne de l'offre grand reporter à france
24 dont julie bonjour emmanuel macron a
donc tranché trois semaines après sa
réélection le président de la république
nomme elisabeth borne à matignon une
femme faut-il le souligner trente ans
après edith cresson sinon pour remarquer
que ce n'est que la deuxième fois qu'un
tel événement se produit en france ça
mérite qu'on en parle sous cet angle et
annie wable après vous mais moi
j'aimerais bien qu'on cesse de souligner
que c'est une femme oui c'est une femme
et oui ça n'a rien d'un à d'anormal donc
mise hormis le fait que je crois en à
changer la dénomination officiellement
blessé première avec un e à la fin
ministre première mini sas et agrumes
ans et saha voilà sa marque le coup on
est en elle-même l'a évoqué alors je
sais pas si on a le sont là disponibles
pour le pour le passé voilà vous allez
entendre justement les premiers mots
d'elisabeth bande sur le perron de
matignon je suis évidemment très ému ce
soir et je ne peux pas m'empêcher
d'avoir une pensée pour la première
femme qui a occupé ses fonctions
edith cresson et peut-être je voudrais
dédier cette nomination à toutes les
petites filles en leur disant aller au
bout de vos rêves et rien ne doit
freiner le combat pour la place des
femmes dans notre société
c'était la nouvelle zélande qui insiste
sur ce moment historique elle a raison
elle en profite c'est justement là là
elle joue bien c'est à dire que c'est
intelligent de me dire que c'est un
exemple pour toutes les femmes pour que
ça devienne justement la norme pour
qu'on s'en étonne plus donc première
ministre nous on dit grand reporter je
sais pas si justement faudrait pas dire
grande je ne sais pas on a en il ya
toujours un problème sur cette
féminisation de deux professions qui
sont quand même relativement encore
très masculine en tout cas dans
l'imaginaire mois on continue
aujourd'hui ça fait 20 ans que grand
reporter faire des yeux ronds quand je
dis quel est mon métier parce que c'est
un métier d'homme dans les stéréotypes
donc voilà elle casse les stéréotypes et
c'est bien mais c'est son bilan qu'il
faut souligner ou son genre
non jean luc mélenchon a souligné le
bilan immédiat non non bien sûr qu'il
faut dire qu'elle est absolument
capables il faut donner ses qualités de
la même façon qu'on parle des qualités
d'un homme quand il est nommé premier
ministre et puis c'est tout là on vous
me faites parler de ça donc j'en parle
mais sinon l'ensemble est il parfait son
antre où effectivement exagéré que l'on
en parle sous cet angle elle juge par
exemple kong et l'américain qui est
pourtant la première femme à la
chancellerie ça n'a pas fait autant de
bruit dit elle en allemagne alors messin
vérifier mais ce n'était pas le même
moment la zélée société change et
visiblement c'est une c'est une volonté
de la part du président de la république
que cela soit noté c'est la soie
souligné gilles belleau fait politique
ou pas quand on regarde lui cacher nos
voisins européens ou dans les grandes
démocraties occidentales par exemple
quand on fait la comparaison pas bien
sûr on pense immédiatement gala merkel
16 ans au pouvoir on pense à margat
l'ère thatcher pendant onze ans au
pouvoir au royaume-uni et benazir bhutto
pakistan fin juillet compris des pays
qui sont pas considérer ces mots comme
des voiles à des pays occidentaux et si
on tente de dresser un bilan au niveau
au niveau européen seule une poignée de
démocraties européennes sont dirigées
par des femmes est principalement dans
les pays du nord on pense à l'estonie on
pense à la finlande avec ça la marine
bien sûr on le voit un coup on la voit
beaucoup également on en parlera
probablement un peu après à 34 ans est
devenue la plus jeune première ministre
en exercice on pense à magdalena
anderson première mini ce fait doit au
danemark à la lituanie mais en fait ce
qui est étonnant et moi j'ai beaucoup
travaillé dans ces pays là mais c'est
que là bas ça n'étonne pas la bande n'en
parle pas et quand j'ai fait des
reportages là bas les gens me disais
mais pourquoi ça continue à vous étonner
et nour souligne oui là il ya vraiment
une démarcation pays du nord et pays du
sud mais la maladie la hiérarchie moins
marquée au sister qu'un chef de
gouvernement peut prendre les transports
en commun et comptables de chacune de
ces dépenses il marie en belgique moi je
suis belge et quand on a une première
ministre belge ça n'a jamais posé de
questions et c'est exactement il ya
moins le protocole à la française qu'on
peut observer ici protocole un peu lourd
voulez vous dire pour autant anne
s'annonce quoi la ligne qui sera suivi
par emmanuel macron où il avait prédit
promis le soir de sa réélection un
changement de méthode de manière de
gouverner qu'indique de ce point de vue
là le parcours d'elisabeth bornes il
avait deux bornes c'est une femme de
gauche mais de gauche un peu pâle cema
c'est pas la gauche gauche donc c'est
sans doute ce qui a aussi retenu le
choix des manuels macron on peut se dire
que c'est une femme qui va sans doute
mener à bien les réformes qu'il faut
mener à bien dans ce second quinquennat
notamment la la réforme des arts et des
retraites et retraite est trop
technocrate c'est ce qui plaît aussi
emmanuel macron voilà face à 161 bobigny
ont 65 ans ce serait donc une femme dit
de gauche qui dès ferait l'héritage de
françois mitterrand mais aujourd'hui il
ya plus de gauche de droite ya plus de
cars quand c'est c'est la souplesse de
tous la fluidité y compris justement au
gouvernement question indique quand même
cette nomination d'elizabeth band c'est
que emmanuel macron ne cherche pas un
personnage politique pour diriger sa
majorité mais cherche davantage une
super directrice de cabinet pour mener à
bien ses réformes et lui continuer à
être le superprésident et ou en tout cas
disons un dirigeant capable
techniquement ensuite de faire à la fois
discuté ces réformes par les partenaires
sociaux et ensuite adopté par
l'assemblée nationale dont on ne sait
pas dire quelle sera la majorité y
compris peut-être l'opposition c'est une
pierre dans le jardin de jean luc
mélenchon cette désignation d'elisabeth
ben même si ce n'est pas dit on un
profil très politique elle peut
néanmoins mettre en difficulté le
dirigeant de lannux probablement c'est
le seul calcul des manuels macron
puisque le but aujourd'hui c'est de
tenter de draguer les sociaux-démocrates
vie ont peur de jean luc mélenchon il ya
beaucoup de gens de gauche qui ont voté
jean luc mélenchon un peu pour faire un
choix utiles aujourd'hui il s'est mal
elle macron le principal opposant c'est
jean luc mélenchon et d'ailleurs on le
voit dans toutes les déclarations
politiques qu'il fait ces temps ci c'est
jean luc mélenchon sa principale cible
donc en prenant une personnalité dit de
gauche même si de gauche un peu pâle
comme le dit les annales instant le but
d' emmanuel macron est très probablement
de draguer cet électorat là à ne vous et
les régions mais où est ce qu'on a le
son alors là j'arrête pas demandé ce
meurin mais parce qu'il n'a pas pas
forcément préparé on a fait ça c'est
vide de jean luc mélenchon justement
j'attends simplement la réponse
pour pouvoir et verona leçon de jean-luc
mélenchon pour l'écouter
il arrive jean luc mélenchon dans un
instant qui a été l'un des premiers
dirigeants politiques à réagir oralement
en plus d'un tweet écoutez
nous avons appris la démission du
premier ministre jean castex qui nous
souhaitons de bonnes vacances
et la nomination de madame elisabeth
bornes comme nouvelle première ministre
de notre pays
cette nomination se porte sur une femme
qui a toutes les compétences et les
qualités personnelles pour assumer la
tâche qui lui a été confié en effet elle
incarnera la continuité de la politique
du président de la république et des
précédents premiers ministres du premier
quinquennat
c'est donc en quelque sorte une nouvelle
saison de maltraitance sociale
écologique qui commence voilà donc là
effectivement la question du dha
présence historique d'une femme à matino
est mise de côté par jean luc mélenchon
il est gêné d'après vous à hiva par la
désignation d'elisabeth bornes ou au
contraire rien je ne sais pas en tout
cas ce que je peux dire c'est que jean
luc mélenchon est partout et que c'est
en cela que c'est un peu comme poutine
pardon d'avoir une obsession avec la
russie mais c'est à dire c'est celui qui
parle qui occupent le terrain donc
j'aurai pris ma chance c'est ce qui fait
moi j'étais au fin fond de l'ukraine
quand c'était le second tour des
élections présidentielles et quelle ne
fut pas ma stupéfaction quand j'ai vu
arriver jean luc mélenchon pratiquement
faire un discours tout de suite après la
perdante marine le pen enfin donc
s'imposer et je crois que c'est encore
c'est vraiment une tactique qu'il a
aujourd'hui une stratégie de
communication c'est d'occuper le terrain
de parler et quoiqu'il est de se faire
entendre avec cette incongruité élisez
moi à matignon voilà oui par têtu et ça
c'est la nouvelle façon de faire de la
politique en france pourquoi pas l'otan
en tout cas puisque là jean luc
mélenchon chouette si les premiers
ministres en concertation avec le
président denis team va être compliqué
sortir la france de l'otan alors ça
reste à voir mais en tout cas où l'otan
bientôt forte de 32 même si la france
reste c'est en tout cas le tour de force
5 est en passe de réussir la russie de
vladimir poutine et oui inquiète de voir
l'ukraine rejoindre le camp occidental
moscou par son invasion a incité
d'autres pays proches à rechercher la
protection de l'alliance atlantique le
fameux article 5 c'est lui qui garantit
la solidarité du bloc en cas d' attaque
contre l'un de ses membres une assurance
devenu indispensable y compris pour des
états jusque là soucieux de leur
neutralité comme la suède et la finlande
puisque c'est d'elle qu'il s'agit après
le cimetière stockholm vient donc
d'officialiser sa demande d'adhésion
écouter
le mieux pour la sécurité de la suède et
pour la sécurité du peuple suédois est
d'intégrer l'otan et de le faire
conjointement avec la finlande nous
quittons une heure pour entrer dans une
nouvelle ère ajoute la première ministre
elle aussi suédoise changement d'ère
anne nivat alors là ça peut compliquer
je trouve parce que justement on peut se
demander quand même si poutine en
poussant la suède et la finlande dans
les bras de l'otan n'a pas fait s'il n'a
pas fait finalement le jeu des
américains et que ce sont les américains
qui sont les grands gagnants pour
l'instant de ceux de ce fameux renouveau
qui n'est pas tellement un nouveau et
pourquoi je dis ça parce que ça
fragilise évidemment si parce que ce
sont les américains qui domine l'otan et
ça fragilise donc ce renforcement de
l'otan l'union européenne donc ça c'est
quelque chose de très important l'union
européenne sortait avait l'air de sortir
renforcée de ce conflit en ukraine et en
fait c'est l'otan qui se renforçaient de
ce conflit en ukraine donc et puis on a
aussi venir poutine qui dit toujours
tout et son contraire donc il dit
quelque chose il menace dans sa
rhétorique il fait peur on l'a tous vu
avec la menace nucléaire et là aussi
avec l'otan mais il vient de dire ce
qu'il vient de dire aujourd'hui sur la
suède s'est pas fait sur la suède et la
finlande s'est pas forcé il retourne en
arrière donc il est toujours dans ce jeu
de menaces et ensuite de minimiser il
nous fait peur il nous fait peur et
l'otan est là a été construite sur la
peur et au sortir de la seconde guerre
mondiale et simplement on peut se
demander si aujourd'hui l'intelligence
c'est de remettre en avant une structure
dont je vous rappelle quand même que le
président emmanuel macron avait dit en
décembre 2021
qu'elle était en mort cérébrale de la
remettre au goût du jour alors qu'en
fait est ce que ça serait pas mieux de
réfléchir à une nouvelle structure qui
serait une structure défensive
occidentales européennes je ne sais pas
je n'ai pas de réponse mais je pense que
être toujours mû par la peur
c'est pas forcément le bon choix devenir
membre pour ces deux pays la suède la
finlande ça s'annonce comme une
formalité julie maintenant qu'on a
changé d'ère comme vous le disiez à
l'instant à savoir que par exemple ces
deux pays ont réussi à convaincre leurs
opinions publiques il ya quelques mois
seuls 20 % de la population dense est là
et bien sûr était favorable à une entrée
dans l'otan une adhésion dans l'otan est
à présent en finlande c'est 70% en suède
un peu moins un peu plus de 50% donc
maintenant que ce chemin là où ils le
veulent c'est clair maintenant que les
ordres ont le vouloir écouter voilà
encore vendredi on était persuadé que
c'était qu'une simple formalité jusqu'à
ce que recep tayyip erdogan le président
turc qu'on fasse des déclarations en
sens inverse pour troubler un peu les
esprits oui bien sûr vu son comportement
st peter's année la suède et la norvège
aurait hébergé
leur reproche de ne pas avoir extrader
une trentaine de membres du pkk le parti
des travailleurs du kurdistan mais en
réalité on peut se poser la question de
quel est le jeu exactement de richesse
adwan certains y voient un certain
marchandage pour tenter notamment
pourquoi pas d'obtenir des équipements
militaires là où les états unis poussent
pour ces adhésions donc donc il va
falloir observer mais ces dernières
heures les turcs ont laissé entendre que
la finlande d'aller dans le bon sens et
qu'ils ne s'opposeraient pas
probablement à une adhésion de ces deux
pays donc cela pourrait prendre entre
quatre mois et un an la dernière
l'adhésion c'est la macédoine du nord et
ça a pris 13 mois alors ça ça donne une
idée de la mesure mais effectivement là
on a deux membres qui de l'intérêt
disons de l'alliance atlantique sont
déjà très intégré dans les structures de
l'otan avec des pib conséquent et
notamment c'est le cas notamment de la
norvège alors vous le disiez à neuf la
dia poutine lui n'a pas manqué de réagir
on va pouvoir l'écouter
le jeu de
en suède je voudrais vous informer chers
collègues que la russie n'a aucun
problème avec ces états un tel
élargissement de l'otan à ces pays ne
constitue pas une menace immédiate pour
nous pour la russie mais le déploiement
d'infrastructures militaires sur les
territoires de ces pays entraînera bien
sûr une réponse
quelle réponse on y va la faire une
réponse il avait dit avant le week-end
technico-militaire vous vous souvenez là
il dit il en traîne ça entraînerait une
réponse ne sait pas laquelle mais c'est
toujours la même chose s'est il ya une
crispation il il fait encore plus peur
par sa rhétorique et puis ensuite il
revient dans l'autre sens tout
simplement donc on va on va on va voir
là la finlande est un pays qui a
plusieurs plus de 1000 km de frontière
avec la russie mais le 300 mille trois
cent oui c'est ça et qui est un pays qui
a énormément souffert de la tacc russe
pendant la seconde guerre mondiale mais
qui depuis avait gardé des bonnes
relations et les finlandais le disent
eux-mêmes avec avec la russie donc c'est
la peur qui a fait s'engager la finlande
et la suède dans une modification totale
de leurs géostratégie du côté fermement
de l'otan mais en fait tout ça ce sont
les conséquences de cette guerre en
ukraine cette guerre en ukraine elle est
en train de bouger toutes les plaques
toutes les plaques tout compenser
complètement un beau diable et
l'amérique est en train de faire la
guerre finalement à la russie sans être
sur le territoire ukrainien et ça c'est
ce que souhaitaient peut-être vladimir
poutine je ne sais pas moi je ne
prétends pas dans sa tête mais il est il
est clair que vladimir poutine est fier
d'avoir se met une telle 10 anni et une
telle peur et d'avoir justement de
provoquer de telles réactions au risque
au risque d'alimenter justement son
principal adversaire l'alliance
atlantique c'est comme le parados green
est pour le moment le terrain militaire
les souffrances des populations civiles
elles sont en ukraine et uniquement dans
la population ukrainienne
tout le reste ce ne sont que des
commentaires et des palabres il faut
vraiment le souligner vous les avez
largement documenté un gîte à nouveau
tous ceux qui nous regardent aa reliera
cc2 ces deux articles que vous avez
publié dans l'hebdomadaire le point du
25 avril et du 5 mai du reportage un
nicolas yves est également dans le
dombasle
julie donne de l'eau concrètement ça va
changer quoi dans le rapport de france
en europe et est ce que ça accroît les
risques d'affrontement avec moscou le
fait d'avoir deux membres
supplémentaires
en europe membre de l'otan en tout cas
la houle inquiet quand même frontaliers
directeur mais 1300 km de frontière on
le rappelle alors la suède et la
finlande ne crois pas du tout à des
représailles armée de la part de moscou
ils pensent davantage à des représailles
dit d'une guerre hybride un quine donc
ils ont l'habitude par exemple une
guerre des informations par rapport par
exemple du hacking du piratage la
norvège a refusé le déploiement de
d'armes nucléaires sur son sol air
justement pour éviter de confronter
directement moscou que ce soit vécu
comme exactement et donc on a déjà vu il
ya quelques semaines par exemple la
déclaration de vladimir zelensky le
président ukrainien a été piraté je
crois que c'est en finlande et je
m'étais rendu notamment en finlande pour
faire un reportage là dessus sur cette
guerre hybride entre la russie et la
finlande et ils ont mis en place des
task force pour tenter de lutter sur sa
d'un point de vue géostratégique ça va
changer beaucoup de choses pour
l'alliance atlantique en revanche merci
beaucoup julien on va devoir s'arrêter
là malheureusement
si on aura l'occasion d'en reparler avec
vous notamment annie va chaque lundi
également avec julie d'un gloss qui nous
fait le plaisir de venir régulièrement
dans cette émission on se retrouve nous
dans moins de trois minutes pour un
nouveau journal rester avec nous dans
parisien
[Musique]